[Musica]
sta arrivando l'inverno e in poco tempo
siamo passati da quei piccoli ritagli di
tessuto che abbiamo avuto il coraggio di
chiamare costumi alle calze calde
morbide sicure siamo passati da quelle
canotte ascellari manco dovessimo lo so
a contare le costole che ci abbiamo tipo
sfida ai maglioni fedeli confortevoli
siamo passati da quelle insulin i
freschi che pesa pizzicano addosso tipo
sudario durante l'estate ai piumoni
confortevoli democratici inclusive i
signori beh questo inverno anche oreo ha
deciso di fare qualcosa di importante si
è fatto un tuffo all'interno del
cioccolato ed è uscito bello coperto e
vestito pronto per l'inverno a questo
punto non mi resta che darvi il
benvenuto a una nuova puntata di cucina
buttata
[Musica]
la ricetta di oggi sono molto contento
di riuscire a farla insieme a oreo che
sono dei prodotti a parte preferiti da
sempre li amo nella loro versione
originale li amo come ingredienti per
altre ricettazioni e li amo anche in
questa edizione limitata nella quale si
sono vestiti per l'ing per l'inverno
perché all'interno bagnata che noi oggi
utilizzeremo per creare una crostata
raga facilissima che vi farà sembrare
iginio massari è arrivato il momento
della vestizione dire che possiamo
cominciare per fare la crosta torneo
avremo bisogno di 38 ore o bagnata di
cui metà neri e metà bianchi 120 g di
burro fuso 500 grammi di cioccolato
fondente questo è solo per decorazione
440 millilitri panna fresca cioccolato
fondente cioccolato bianco confettini
arancia candita e ribes perché tutti il
minimo i ribes vederlo fare sarà
prendere i nostri biscotti e sminuzzarle
perché poi ci andiamo di più minipimer
proprio aggressivo perché dovremmo
proprio renderli proprio sbriciolati
guardate qui
ha capito per lavoro tagliamo bello su
rumore come camera scusa ma bellissimo
centro più grande
[Musica]
attenzione quando fate questo lavoro
perché fuori sono avvolgenti e
cioccolatosi ma dentro hanno una loro
classica fragranza quindi guerra che il
beauty ti sta dando
tra colori dopo dieci minuti di
procedura
no non è inutile perché minipimer tutti
bravi e usarlo ma in due secondi gray la
tempesta di sabbia
è questo qui in una scala di qualità
questo dove si posizionato sento caldo
mi si stanno fondendo in mano un senso
di insicurezza quando tengo questa cosa
adesso qui ce l'abbiamo che adesso
andiamo al volo a prendere il burro
sciogliamo in microonde per un minuto
manco andate ciò che è proprio il burro
nel microonde come buono va bene così
non devo ammettere e incorporare con i
biscotti
realizzate nella valpe rivare abbiamo
dei guanti da cucina quelli temo di no
ma che cazzo non c'è niente incorporate
per bene tutto è una ricetta che sopra
scritto solamente un nome successo di
bruciato e mm ma
con la facilità con la gioia col sorriso
quando lo fa dovete fare così il livello
bravissimo sia una certa però voglio
essere preciso permesso composto nella
tortiera lo fate riposare per 30 minuti
in frigo e passiamo alla crema unito
della crema cioccolato fondente e
iniziamo ha
tagliato quanta soddisfazione
ma l'europa non lo facevo finta
rate capito farlo scena e mettiamo in
una pentolina
siamo fatti le spaghettate da 2 kg a
casa questa qui in confronto è una tazza
c'eravamo in quella pentola no ecco ci
va prima la panna e cioccolato
nel frattempo mentre tagliate un molta
facilità cioccolato mettete la panna
all'interno di una pentolina iniziate a
scaldarla con questo si accendono mai
attaccato bene il caso le solite
organico blair rami blend di
anarchia ma poi le botte di anarchia voi
volete lee o malley
fallisca noi siamo due alleati se si
guarda l'ultima volta è stato bruto a
cesare che gliela testa
le menti metti insieme ragazzi non lo so
ma
se succede qualcosa sta succedendo
qualcosa di positivo è che sto
scherzando
non ci credo pazzesco non ci credo
[Musica]
dopo dieci minuti quindi quando pochino
si è raffreddata arriva il momento più
erotico forse bambini stop
[Musica]
di quattro ore in frigo il tempo di far
solidificare tutto quanto
la crostata loreo è estremamente facile
di per sé quindi l'unica cosa per
rendere veramente unico questo piatto e
buttarci un po di creatività ecco perché
prenderemo gli olè o bagnata seeley
decoreremo visto che si prestano
benissimo a questo tipo di lavorazione e
soprattutto schenone siamo anche in un
periodo che ci sta parto subito col
procedimento e adriano se faccia mettere
il cioccolato fondente spezzettato in
una ciotolina mentre nell'altra ci metto
quello bianco di utilizzare un pochino
come colori ma se potessimo pensa che ci
sono quelli che spaccano con la testa a
7 fine di mattoni e io ma sei fortissimo
un giro velocissimo a microonde mi fa
ridere che il microonde nella zona
clandestina e adesso ragazzi il momento
della verità le decorazioni avrei potuto
scegliere fare delle cose che una
persona di livello medio basso avrebbe
potuto fare consiglio se volete di
segnare col cioccolato non usatelo
appena al disciolto cercato un pochino
di aspettare che si rapprenda in modo da
poterlo maneggiare meglio proprio il
minimo a versailles
utilizzate delle sac à poche niente deve
sembrare che non avete fatto nemmeno un
taglio
movimento conosciamo tutti quanti e
realtà bisognerà tagliarla dopo che
scemo grazie naturalmente vi invito a
condividere su instagram quelle che
saranno le vostre creazioni almeno in
questo non fatemi sentire da sola tanto
che ti verranno odio jean marc layton
[Musica]
portato via che ti chiamano i francesi
inglesi e bellissimo proviamo una vera
un tocco di 6 m ma non è uguale a magna
soluzione stesso sempre di chiamare
gianmarco beh beh beh beh
trasmetti tre mesi qualcuno ha capito
che film fatto di gioco sapere nei
commenti qui sotto si conta non sono
male il completo step successivo a fare
invece due decorazioni più semplice
perché questi artifici hai sbagliato
perché è il clima tagliato ma voi siete
la polizia o delle persone cioè che
collaborano nella creazione del
programma di cucina più bello che esista
sul web i
diritti che carino da un candito glielo
abbassiamo col coltello adesso è ridotto
[Musica]
possiamo fare l'arena bottone di
cioccolato fissiamo il naso pochetto
allegro sembra molto arrabbiato navale
che gli hanno menato guardano a questo
punto facciamo entrare
meravigliosa stupenda perfetta una meta
un pochino che per celebrare questi olio
bagnata bianchi ce la facciamo tutta
quanta tipo spennellando quadro astratto
kandisky puro
[Musica]
traiano piazziamo a questo punto i
biscotti proprio al centro del cairo da
questo lato di mortizza ricordo
io non potevo fare più di questo questo
è il massimo ragazzi se sapete fare
meglio fate voi che fate provenire ed
accademici di instagram muove la
notevole qui posso dire molto bella con
bella direi che è bella dovremmo
scoprire avesse buona ma prima di
passare all'assaggio volevo chiedervi
qual è il vostro bagnata ha preferito
bianco o nero la mia posizione umile è
nero tra poi ti sciacqui la bocca col
bianco per poter riattaccare il nero e
quel punto in una sorta di unione da
criceto andare con tutti e due e il cool
mario una sorta di apoteosi del piacere
e allo stesso tempo iscriversi al canale
mettendo un pollice in su sporco di
cioccolato anche solo come segno di
estrema gratitudine per avermi fatto
svoltare una ricetta così facile che per
arrivare a fare un figurone fatti in
questo tipo li potete trovare sul sito
di oreo da veramente se lascio il link
dell'info box dove troverete di tutto
dal da cheesecake fino al tiramisù c'è
di tutto e per il resto direi che
possiamo passare la stagione
[Musica]
quindi prima e poi
due fasi doveva esatto dai genio davvero
non l'ho fatta io non potrei proprio
dirmi niente per questo nome fatto
della composizione no coseno e mangiato
che si è
praticamente fine perché vai
ma sarà raggiunto due così diverse
ammazza che t'è successo e il biscotto
sotto che non avete critiche
ma guardate mente se ne andava cioè far
west che cos'è
ma quindi non anche approvata
to dire che a questo punto
ai ragazzi sahariani alla fine di questo
video spero che vi abbia divertito
ringrazio al colore o per questa
bellissima collaborazione e voi per
averci seguito fatica per qua sotto che
cosa vi piacerebbe vedere all'interno di
questo format noi ci vediamo domenica
prossima con un nuovo cucina mutata la
vita è un biscotto ma se piove si
scioglie
che vuol dire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la vita un biscotto ma se piove si
scioglie